[音楽]
[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは
私は牛村波と言います
もともと小学校の生成をしていたのですが
5年ほど前に辞め今は子供のより良い育ち
を支える会という会を作って子供と関わる
活動しています
主に地域の子供たちや不登校の子どもたち
の居場所を作って一緒に遊んだり学んだり
しています
学校の先生を辞めた今も学校の外で
たくさんの子供たちと関わることができて
私は子は幸せです
先生をしていた時も楽しくて充実していた
のですがその頃より
払っていることが多くなりました
自分らしく生きていると言えるようになり
そんな自分が好きです
みなさんは自分のことが好きですか
心から捉えているでしょうか
何のために毎日働いたり学校に行ったりし
ているのでしょうか
今日は私が停職とも思える学校の先生を
止め
立ち止まって気づいたことをお話ししたい
と思います
私が小学校の先生になりたいと思ったのは
小学校2年生の時でした
その時の担任の先生に憧れたことが
きっかけです
先生はその年赴任してきたあかりとん
背の高いすらっとした若い女性の先生でし
た
ドッチボールがとても強くて
小学生相手にも手加減せず全力で遊んで
くれました
先生が黒板やノートに書く字はとても
きれいでしかも
イラストも上手で
私は先生のようにへ味を上手に描けるよう
になりたいなと思っていました
怒ったら怖いけど頑張ったことは褒めて
くれたし
できるようになったことは一緒に喜んで
くれました
先生のようにカッコよくて優しくてなんで
もできる先生になりたいと思いました
大学は迷わず教育学部に進みました
採用試験を受けて
念願の小学校の先生になることができまし
た
子どものころからの夢が叶った私は嬉しく
て張り切って仕事を頑張りました
先生の仕事は楽しくてやりがいがありまし
た
子どもたちに勉強を教えて
できた分かったと言ってもらうととても
嬉しくなりました
運動会や学芸なら学芸会だけど経ちデー
みんなで取り組み成功した時には達成感が
ありました
休み時間や放課後の子どもたちとの雑談や
日々の何気ない会話のやりとりも私の好き
な時間でした
もちろんドッチボールも全力でやりました
毎年
クラスの担任をして1年が終わる3月には
1年間の成長を振り返って
子どもたちも自分も褒めてあげたくなる
ものでした
楽しいことばかりではありませんでしたが
やはり私にぴったりの仕事だなと先生で
ある自分を誇らしく思っていました
先生美なって10年ほどの間に3人の
子どもにも恵まれ
家ではお母さん
職場では先生と団体忙しくなっていきまし
た
毎日バタバタと走り回って
1週間をやっとを得るような毎日でした
学校でも教員としての経験を積むにつれ
任される役割や仕事が多くなってきました
こんな授業をしたい
子どもたちにこんな体験をさせてあげたい
願望がたくさんあるのに
やらなければならないことが多く
やりたいことがやれないもどかしさが募り
ました
また私自身が納得のいかない
学校のきまりを子供たちに守らせなければ
ならないというジレンマも少なくありませ
んでした
新遠いなぁと思いながらも今までなんとか
やってきたし
頑張れば乗り切れると思っていました
私にできないことはないと思っていたの
です
教員生活も15年目に入った頃
相変わらず子供たちとの毎日は楽しかった
です
でもだんだんと子供達と話をゆっくりと
聞く時間が減っていき
ちょっとしたことで注意したり
強く叱ってしまう自分がいました
家でもは過去とゆっくり過ごす時間が取れ
なくて寂しい思いをさせていたのではない
かと思います
時々ふと我に返り反省はするのですが
やはり時間にも心にも余裕ができません
でした
うまくいかない
でももっと頑張らなくちゃ
自分で耳鼻自分を追い込みました
モヤモヤした気持ちが大きくなりました
心と体のバランスが崩れていくのは気が
ついていましたし
だんだんと自信がなくなっていくのも感じ
ていました
それでも私の中に仕事を辞めるという選択
肢はなかったので
なんとかこの状況を良くする方法はないか
と考え続けました
けれどもあるとき
ふと金と緊張の糸がきれい
私は学校の先生を止めることになったの
です
仕事を辞めて私は望んでいた時間を手に
入れました
学校に行かなくていい
自由な時間がある
そう思うとワクワクしてきました
今まで出来なかったことをやったりいけ
なかったとことところにも行ってみました
やりたいことが自由に出来て楽しかった
です
でも行くべきところがなくなったので心に
ぽっかり穴があいたようなそんな感じがし
ていました
先生でなくなった自分は何者でもない自分
でした
周りのみんなが毎日働いて頑張っているの
を見ると
取り残されたような気持ちになりました
突然仕事も収入も失ったわけですから
この先私はどうなるんだろうと不安になり
ました
でも今まで先生の仕事しかしてこなかった
ので自分に他に何ができるのか
全く思いつきませんでした
このままでいいのだろうか
そう思い続けていた私は
半年ほど経ってじっとしていられなくなり
動いてみることにしました
まず地域の子供たちに自分が得意な
そろばんや習字や勉強を教えてみることに
しました
子どもたちができた分かった面白いと言っ
てくれるので嬉しくなりました
たくさん本を読んだり動画でいろいろな人
の話を聞いてみました
自分とは違う生き方や考え方があるんだな
と思いました
それを真似てみるとなんだか違う自分に
なれる気がしました
ある対話の場に勇気を出して参加してみ
ました
そこで出会った人たちは私の話を否定せず
に聴いてくれました
やりたいことがあると話すと応援してくれ
協力してくれました
一人じゃないって思いました
思い描いた人生が思い通りにいかなくなり
私はすっかり自信をなくしてしまっていた
のですが
自分から一歩踏み出したことをきっかけに
卵弾世界が広がっていき今ではこれで
良かったんだと思えるようになりました
同時に今まで自分が見てきた世界は何と
狭かったのかと痛感しました
今私はもっといろんなところに行って
いろんな人に会いたい
いろんなことを知りたいとワクワクしてい
ます
これが学ぶということなのだと今では思い
そして自分がやりたいことも自分にでき
そうなことも考えられるようになりました
やっぱり私は子どもの育ちや学びを
サポートする仕事がしたいのだと気づく
ことができました
生成を止めてから気づいたことが3つあり
ます
私の中で子どもへの見方が変わったのです
一つ目は子どもは大人が先回りしてレール
を敷いてやらなくても育つということです
以前は私は先生だから親だからと良かれと
思って子供たちに指示アドバイスをしてい
ました
言うことを聞かなかったり思った通りと
反応が返ってこないと
なんで大人の言うことを聞かないのと子供
のせいにしていました
でも子供たちと関わる中で大人が子どもの
ためを思って心配し過ぎることは
大人の思いを落ち着けてしまうことになり
かえって
子どもたちのやりたいことや彼らの持つ
可能性をつぶしてしまうことになるのでは
ないかと思うようになりました
そう思えるようになった理由として私自身
が子供たちに対して指導や評価をしなくて
よくなったっていうことが大きいと思い
ます
今まで積もっていたレンズがクリアになっ
たように
十数に子供たちを見られるようになりまし
た
二つ目は子どもはすごいということです
大人から見ると子供は小さくて何も知ら
ない何もできない弱い存在と思い1勝ち
です
ところがちょっと目線を下げてみるとそう
ではないことに気がつきます
子供はちゃんと自分の思いや考えを持って
いますし
なぜと思ったことは素直に口にします
子供同士初めてあってもすぐに打ち解ける
し友達と喧嘩してもいつのまにか仲直りし
ています
好きなことにはとことん興味を示す4
打ち込んでぐんぐん上達します
私たち大人も子どものころはやりたいこと
を思うままにやっていたのではない
でしょうか
大人になると素直になれなかったり
まず頭で考えてしまったりして
行動に移せないことありますよね
子どもの思いのままに行動するところには
感心しますし羨ましくも思います
私が関わっている地域活動
堀川子供団の小学生に
こんな質問してみました
大人にして欲しい事ってある
そうするとこんな答えが返ってきました
活動するための場所等金は自分たちで用意
できないからをとなり助けてほしい
私たち大人がその通りにサポートしている
と子どもたちはどんどん自分たちの力で
活動を進めていきます
困ったことや分からないことがあると聞き
にいきますがそんな時には
だったらこうしてみたら
と言うと
なるほどやってみるとまた活動に戻ります
好きな事や面白い事に夢中になっている
ときの子供の顔は笑っています
とてもいい顔しています
そして楽しいとどんどんアイディアが湧い
てくるようです
子どもってすごい
子どもたちの姿から学ぶことは多くて私は
子供を尊敬するようになりました
三つ目は子どもが笑っているためにはまず
大人が笑っていることが大事ということ
です
今までの私は自分はしんどくて笑えてい
ないのに子どもたちには笑っていてほしい
と願っていました
そのために無理して楽しいふりをしたり
しんどいのに大丈夫だよっプス強がったり
思考と行動がずれていました
それが知らず知らずのうちにストレスと
なって積み重なっていたのだと思います
今ではとにかく自分が楽しむように心がけ
ています
そうするとそばにいる子供たちもそれに
つられて笑って楽しそうにしています
なんだ楽しむ来てこういうことかと気持ち
が楽になりました
先生やお父さんお母さんが笑っていると
子どもたちはそれだけで嬉しくて安心でき
ます
心からもらいたいと思ったら幸せそうに
笑っている人のそばにいて一緒に笑って
いるのが一番の近道だと思います
是非試してみてください
子供はこれからの未来を担う大切な存在
です
可能性に満ち溢れています
私は子どもに関わる大人の一人として
子どもが自分らしく
いつも笑っていられる社会をつくっていき
たいとおもいます
そのためには子どもの育ちを支える私たち
大人が幸せであることが何より大事です
子育てをしているお父さんお母さんも学校
の先生も
子どものことを考える前にまずは自分が
自分らしく生きられているか
心から笑えているか
今一度自分自身に問いかけてみてください
しんどい時には誰かに助けを求めてもいい
疲れたときは立ち止まって一休みしても
いい
そして少し元気になったら一歩を踏み出す
きっかけを見つけに行けばいい
1人でできないことはみんなでやればいい
そう思えるようになった私は今
なりたかった自分にやっとなれた気がして
います
これから楽しそうにバラを大人や子どもが
もっともっと増えるように活動していき
たいとおもいます
皆さんも皆さんの隣にいる人や
目の前の人達を笑顔にしていってください
そのためには皆さん自身が自分らしく生き
幸せだと思える生き方をしてください
みんなで一緒に幸せになりましょう
頑張って